el mensaje que salió de esta reunión es
bastante claro se reanudarán esas
conversaciones que se llevan a cabo en
viena en busca de reanudar ese llamado
disip
por las siglas en inglés o el plan de
acción integral conjunto firmado en el
2015 y que había quedado prácticamente
muerto desde que el presidente o ex
presidente norteamericano donald trump
retiró a eeuu del acuerdo en el 2018
desde que llegó a la presidencia del
presidente giovanni después al llegar a
la presidencia el presidente iraní
ebrahim raisi se habían ido retomando
conversaciones para revivir el acuerdo
pero éstas habían quedado prácticamente
estancadas en marzo cuando se realmente
se levantó la mesa con un texto que ya
existe y que tenían que responder
ciertas preguntas y tomar ciertas
decisiones tanto en washington como en
teherán pues bien borrel ha dicho que él
había pedido venir a teherán a decir que
se reactivarán estas conversaciones que
era hora de que ambos países con texto
contestarán a estas preguntas dijo que
él ponía a disposición su equipo para
servir de intermediario para que sigan
estas conversaciones recordemos que ni
washington y teherán se sientan a la
mesa junto pero borrel también ha dicho
que el mundo es totalmente diferente
desde febrero de lo que él llamó esa
brutal ataque de rusia a ucrania y dijo
que volver a reactivar este acuerdo era
importantísimo para la seguridad y la
estabilidad no solamente de la región
sino del mundo y también les dijo a los
iraníes que esto era importante para
ellos esta tarde siguen las
conversaciones aquí en teherán y estamos
convocados la prensa extranjera para
otra rueda de prensa ya independiente
del ministerio de relaciones
internacionales de irán esta noche y
veremos qué otras cosas tiene para
contar josep borrell